ah merci c'est bon ça fait ça fait du
bien de vous retrouver dans les 25 ans
de carrière la physique particulier pour
accepter ça robert avait pu le faire aux
collègues ontariens
c'est mon chien qui ne fait la fête on
est tous mes chiens viennent de là
espère du coup il se tient à carreau
si ça se passe pas bien à la maison à
pire tourne évidemment tu peux pas faire
trois femmes
les ados à la maison ils foutent rien de
ne rien faire si ils nettoient parterre
seul truc qu'il faut mais sans s'en
rendre compte comme une marche comme ça
on leur a mis deux épouses prévenance
t'imagines dans bienvenue chez les
ch'tis michel galabru au lieu de dire
laurent de dire et les odeurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]